bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages sur Public Sénat et c'est une
émission spéciale que je vous propose ce
soir évidemment consacré aux résultats
des élections au sénatoriales d'hier
avec nos experts on va d'abord analyser
les nouveaux équilibres au sein d'une
majorité de droite et du centre qui
reste la première force politique de la
Haute Assemblée comprendre la
concurrence accrue ce soir entre deux
groupes qui soutiennent l'action
d'Emmanuel Macron Renaissance qui baisse
et horizon qui progressent décoder aussi
le sujet le succès pardon de la
stratégie de la gauche sénatoriale PS PC
et vers l'union fait la force mais sans
la France insoumise et puis enfin tirer
les leçons de l'entrée au Sénat de trois
élus du rassemblement national et puis
dans trois quarts d'heure c'est un débat
100% politique que je vous propose
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne pour le parti
LR les républicains Claude malürées pour
horizon Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie pour
le Parti socialiste et le nouveau venu
Yann brossa pour le parti communiste ils
vont pouvoir confronter leurs arguments
leurs idées notamment sur le projet de
loi immigration et puis sur la
planification écologique détaillée cet
après-midi par Emmanuel Macron
ces engagements ont été tenus et la
planification qui a été validée
aujourd'hui et le fruit de 14 mois à la
fois de travaux de concertation dans le
cadre des conseils nationaux de la
refondation qui a été largement débattue
on est voilà certaines des mesures
annoncées par le chef de l'État le Sénat
veut rester un contre-pouvoir face au
président de la République et les grands
électeurs l'ont conforté dans ce rôle le
nouveau visage de la chambre haute
scruter par raydamrabbit
premier renseignement de ces
sénatoriales si la droite conserve sa
majorité elle perd néanmoins quelques
sièges la faute notamment à des
candidatures dissidentes je trouve c'est
plutôt une performance dans les temps
politiques qui courent qui sont marqués
par l'instabilité au contraire d'avoir
cette forme de stabilité et je pense
justement que beaucoup de grands
électeurs apprécient le travail du Sénat
la gauche dans son ensemble remplit
largement ses objectifs je pense que
nous allons progresser que globalement
l'objectif que je m'étais fixé avec mes
collègues assassis et gonta de sang
voilà une barre de sang c'est la terre
de gauche devrait être tutoyée
potentiellement voire même atteinte ou
dépasser les socialistes conservent leur
nombre d'élus les communistes ressortent
renforcés et les écologistes font une
percée avec notamment l'élection de la
benjamine du Sénat Mathilde Rivier 29
ans
parmi ces nouveaux élus on retrouve
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle
Yannick Jadot moi je vais être au Sénat
pour à la fois porter tout le projet
écologiste sur l'immigration sur la
décentralisation sur la proportionnelle
mais faire en sorte que la France soit
la hauteur du défi écologique sans
ancrage local profond la majorité
présidentielle limite finalement les
pertes on nous avait prédit Regina déjà
la 3 ans pour ma propre élection tout le
monde avait dit que je reviendrais pas
je me souviens aujourd'hui je pense qu'à
cette heure-ci nous sommes 21 on peut
être encore un peu plus de mal donc on
peut pas parler de défaite de du groupe
présidentiel au Sénat enfin horizon le
parti d'Édouard Philippe gagne quelques
sièges le rassemblement national fait
lui son retour au Palais du Luxembourg
avec trois nouveaux sénateurs
on analyse tous ces résultats famille
politiques par famille politique avec
Lucile Schmidt bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes membre de la rédaction de la
revue l'esprit et co-auteur de ce livre
Emmanuel Macron à contretemps publié aux
éditions Bayard Bruno kotrèze bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes polytologue
et chercheur au CNRS et aussi prof
steward show bonsoir et bienvenu
directeur d'études c'est cantar public
Mathieu croissanto éditoris politique
bonsoir bonsoir à tous certains d'entre
vous étaient déjà là pour la soirée
électorale hier merci d'être fidèle au
poste Bruno et Mathieu lucide commencent
avec vous peut-être par la majorité
sénatoriale qui reste ancrée à droite ou
plutôt au centre droit est-ce que c'est
pas le centre qui tire le plus profit de
ce scrutin oui en tout cas ce qui est
très intéressant c'est qu'effectivement
il y a davantage au sénateurs sont
tristes et comme c'était rappelé y
compris par Bruno Retailleau bon c'est
une stabilité qui est un petit peu
écornée et au moment où il y a un
certain nombre de grands projets de loi
comme la loi immigration qui arrive la
question c'est est-ce que ça va au fond
alors même que on nous disait les
macronistes sont faibles même s'ils
disent qu'ils limitent les dégâts est-ce
que ça permettra de trouver des
alliances ailleurs alors que
effectivement chacun se compte c'est à
dire qu'il y a des sénateurs horizons je
rappelle qu'ils appartiennent à la
majorité présidentielle a priori mais
ils sont horizons et les centres ils
appartiennent pas la majorité
présidentielle mais au fond ils sont
macro-compatibles donc le fait que
Emmanuel Macron ne se représente pas
fait qu'on peut chacun se conter et au
fond être un peu à géométrie variable et
sans doute pouvoir aller du côté du
macronisme et de la défense de certains
projets de loi je trouve ça intéressant
et du coup la question des étiquettes
elle n'emporte rien sur la question de
ce qui peut se passer ensuite il faudra
voir comment c'est majorité à géométrie
variable vont pouvoir se faire
effectivement et c'est très intéressant
parce que on va vous proposer là tout de
suite un coup d'oeil aux nouvelles
hémicycle avec toutes toutes les
pincettes possibles parce que c'est
presque trop tôt pour vous proposer ça
mais c'est une projection qui est basée
sur les informations de la rédaction web
de Public Sénat et on trouve donc 135 l
R53 union centrist 17 Renaissance alors
déjà on le voit par rapport à ce que
disait François patriar dans le sujet
nous on est en dessous 18 indépendants
c'est à dire horizon 15 du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen ensuite
65 socialistes communistes 16
écologistes et puis il y a des inclables
et des non inscrits Bruno cotress on a
pris un risque en faisant ça parce que
déjà rien que dans la partie bleue de
l'hémicycle il y a je ne sais pas
combien de nuances de bleu quoi oui il y
a plusieurs nuances de bleu et c'est
vrai que le diable va se cacher dans les
détails parce que si on prend
effectivement les chiffres qui sont
présentés là on voit une sorte de
stabilité un peu en trompe l'oeil
effectivement parce qu'on partait 245
républicains en fait il y avait 115
républicains et il y avait 30 qui
étaient apparentés ou rattachés donc on
imagine qu'entre le bleu foncé voilà le
bleu ciel il y a peut-être encore des
choses mais voilà c'est c'est on va voir
là dans les prochains jours on va savoir
précisément
de ranger dans les différentes boîtes ça
le tableau va se stabiliser à un moment
donné mais effectivement on voit qu'il y
a pas mal de choses qui se passent
effectivement vous avez raison sur les
dans les couleurs de bleu que vous
affichez bleu ciel bleu foncé on voit
que la majorité va rester effectivement
comme ça vient d'être souligné on voit
que la question du centre décidément la
définition du centre va être l'objet de
beaucoup d'attention entre maintenant
ces élections sénatoriales et puis
toutes les échéances parce que
progressivement plus on va se rapprocher
de la grande échéance l'élection
présidentielle et puis cette question va
devenir importante effectivement il y a
des centristes qui sont dans la majorité
sénatoriale qui ne sont pas tous
nécessairement dans la majorité
présidentielle mais Macron compte
beaucoup sur pendant le reste de son de
son mandat il y a des il y a des
républicains qui ont entendent bien
peser au Sénat mais les républicains du
Sénat ne regardent pas tout ça de la
même manière que les républicains de
l'Assemblée nationale donc voilà un
tableau un peu compliqué de mais
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'il nous
dit des choses et passionnant à analyser
steward show on a on a ce sentiment d'un
que les grands électeurs ont quand même
conforté la majorité sénatoriale de
centre droite dans ce rôle de
contre-pouvoir alors on verra comment
seront évolue dans les dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines notamment effectivement avec la
loi immigration mais est-ce que c'est la
leçon principale que vous tirez ensuite
on rentrera un peu plus dans le détail
la leçon principale c'est que ces
élections elles devraient susciter un
peu plus d'intérêt dans l'opinion
publique parce qu'effectivement il y a
des signaux faibles assez fautes
d'Emmanuel Macron qui a pris la parole à
20h hier soir pardon sans doute mais en
tout cas je trouve qu'il y a une
tectonique des plaques effectivement au
sens politique qui se qui se joue alors
oui ça traduit à la fois l'ancrage
territorial des différents partis
politiques on en parlait précédemment
sur la majorité présidentielle qui
confirme finalement la difficulté que
qu'elle a aujourd'hui à s'en créer
territorialement c'est un peu en ligne
aussi d'ailleurs avec les élections
réfléchit pas de 2020 on se rappelle la
droite quand même qui sort ressort très
renforcé la majorité présidentielle avec
des résultats plutôt décevants donc là
on a quand même une forme d'alignement
avec les élections intermédiaires de
2020 deuxième élément je parlais de
l'opinion totale on voit bien
qu'effectivement l'enjeu ça sera le
centre j'avais presque le centre de
gravité politique qui va se jouer à
travers les différents partis parce
qu'en fait les Français même s'ils sont
entre guillemets que 33% à se dire selon
mes confrères 10 fois intéressés par les
sénatoriales vous avez tout aussi
Français sur 10 qui estime que le Sénat
va avoir un rôle est un rôle très
important dans la vie politique
française par rapport à 2015 c'est un
bon de 19 points ça c'est le résultat
des 18 mois écoulés
dans un contexte politique avec majorité
relative à l'Assemblée nationale qui va
donner finalement beaucoup de lumière au
débat et aux enjeux que que pour nous
proposer le débat parlementaire au Sénat
Mathieu vous avez participé à notre
soirée électoral hier pendant plus de la
moitié de la soirée qu'est-ce qui vous a
frappé les de l'Intérieur quelles leçons
vous avez commencé à tirer en voyant la
les premiers résultats tombés alors on a
toujours ce sentiment que tout le monde
a gagné ça c'est bon c'est un grand
classique des soirées électorales et
puis que commence maintenant aussi un
peu la danse du ventre c'est à dire que
pour tous ces sénateurs qui ne sont pas
encore bien apparentés ou qu'on peut
choisir le groupe je peux vous dire que
les téléphones sonnent et que là on est
dans une c'est pour ça qu'en fait il
faut expliquer les spectateurs qu'on
n'arrive pas à donner pour ça qu'on peut
pas c'est pour ça qu'on a qui dit 21
alors que nous on est plutôt parce que
lui il compte sur quatre sénateurs
peut-être qui pourrait le rejoindre
alors que ces quatre sénateurs ont
peut-être promis à d'autres de les
rejoindre donc il y a comme une forme de
de tour supplémentaire qu'il faut bien
comprendre ensuite ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre aussi ce qui est toujours
frappant au Sénat et même pour l'avenir
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de véritablement
de discipline partisane au Sénat
c'est-à-dire les parties dans leur siège
de partie ne dicte pas le vote des
sénateurs qui ont on l'a beaucoup dit
sur ce plateau mais une autonomie
politique pour beaucoup d'entre eux pas
tous certains sont alignés les
directives du parti mais d'autres sont
capables d'abord ils représentent leur
territoire de défendre les intérêts de
leur territoire mais aussi de faire
valoir leur principe et leur valeur et
on a souvent vu dans les votes au Sénat
des groupes parfois se diviser sur des
grands sujets de société sur des sujets
de principes républicains parce que
certains estimaient que voilà le groupe
n'avait pas à dicter sa loi et que
chacun pouvait voter comme il le
souhaitait donc du coup la lisibilité
c'est une chance en fait pour Emmanuel
Macron parce que c'est vrai que ça peut
donner l'idée qu'il pourra aller piocher
ici ou là des majorités constituées de
un peu comme le faisait au fond Michel
Rocard avec l'Assemblée nationale quand
il était sans majorité relative et que
il allait piocher ici ou là des
centristes ici ou là des communistes
selon les textes de loi voilà c'est
comparaison n'est pas raison mais en
tout cas ce Sénat ne vote pas de façon
uniforme et mécanique il faut le
rappeler à ceux qui nous regardent et
donc ça expliquer effectivement on va
écouter un passage de
une réaction de du président du groupe
Renaissance ici au Sénat François
Patriat alors il annonçait déjà désire
soit cet objectif d'être au-delà des
vins sénateurs et sénatrices le groupe
contrairement à ce que nous a prédit de
descendre pas demain au dessous de 20 je
pense que c'est une belle résistance
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui le contexte politique dans
le contexte qui est évoqué aujourd'hui
dans l'environnement après tout ce soir
je peux dire que je respire un peu je
sais pas si vous étiez encore là Bono
cotresses hier soir mais on a fait un
débat avec les présidents enfin quatre
présidents et présente de groupes et il
y avait Hervé Marseille président du
groupe Union centriste face à François
Patriat et rue Marseille qui nous
racontait justement qui avait déjà des
des tractations etc etc c'est ce qui est
en train de se jouer et c'est un
classique de la vie politique c'est pas
d'ailleurs c'est pas forcément
critiquable non c'est un grand classique
de la vie politique et c'est un grand
classique des élections dès lors qu'il y
a pas beaucoup d'électeurs et où on a le
sentiment qu'effectivement on doit
peut-être un peu moins tenir compte de
ce qui s'est passé il y aura
rétractation parce que symboliquement
c'est vrai que si le décompte de Public
Sénat était le final c'est à 17 à passer
de 24
c'est une réduction d'un quart des
effectifs du groupe et donc
effectivement quand on le met en
pourcentage d'un seul coup ça fait
l'effet un peu d'une défaite un peu
cuisante alors que si c'est 20 21
il y a aussi celles et ceux qui sont
présentés en dissidence et qui vont
revenir au bercail ça c'est un grand
classique
dans les prochaines heures et sans doute
que que certains soient qui sont qui
étaient en dissidente soit qui sont
présentés de manière un peu plus
autonome ils attendent peut-être aussi
qu'on leur fasse de bonnes proposition
c'est un jeu qui joue qui se joue à deux
et sans doute que la danse du ventre
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure bah il
y en a qui peuvent un peu faire monter
les enchères c'est un grand classique
aussi qui est-ce qui va me faire les
propositions les plus intéressantes de
me faire une place de choix dans
certaines instances de me donner un rôle
un peu plus un peu plus visible bref de
ce point de vue là c'est de la c'est de
la politique tel qu'on le connaît
toujours dans les institutions dans les
assemblées il y a quand même Lucile
Schmitt la défaite de Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'État à la citoyenneté en
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'était seulement du
gouvernement à se présenter à ses
élections sénatoriales et puis d'une
manière générale ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est que il y a des terres qui
étaient si on regarde les précédents
scrutins plutôt favorables au
macronistes ils ont pas forcément
performé sur ces terres-là oui il y a la
question aussi des Français de
l'étranger c'est à dire que le fait qui
est zéro sénateur macroniste chez les
Français à l'étranger alors qu'Emmanuel
Macron a été très largement en tête
c'est un point important après je
voudrais rappeler que en
Nouvelle-Calédonie il y a des enjeux
politiques particuliers il y a la
question de l'indépendance il y a le
troisième référendum auquel les
abandonnent dépendantistes ont décidé de
pas participer donc c'est comme une
trois j'allais dire c'est un tour
supplémentaire par rapport au débat sur
l'indépendance et je pense qu'elle avait
à la fois un certain courage et en même
temps peut-être une certaine
inconscience de se présenter dans ce
contexte donc il y a un vrai sujet qui
est particulier
ce qui est intéressant c'est plutôt que
je crois que sur la question du centre
qu'on évoquait il y a mon avis beaucoup
de gens qui souffrent sont tristes au
Sénat simplement il faut pas se dire
trop Macron je pense qu'il y a une vraie
question sur le fait de ne pas afficher
le fait qu'on pourrait être avec le
président de la République après je
voulais aussi rappeler vous disiez que
au fond tout est conforme aux élections
municipales c'est aussi mécaniques
c'est-à-dire qu'on le sait ce sont les
grands électeurs qui sont mage très
majoritairement des conseillers
municipaux donc il y a dans cette
collection c'était pas fort on a fait
plusieurs déjà on disait que c'était
souvent vrai plus vrai on va dire dans
les grandes villes et moins dans les
dans les espèces de truc très complexe
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un côté mécanique
sur le fait que si vous n'êtes pas du
tout implanté localement vous risquez
pas de faire des bons scores en revanche
si vous êtes bien implanté localement la
question des personnalités peut jouer et
moi je voyais moi qui connaît bien les
Hauts-de-Seine que par exemple la
dissidence dans les Hauts-de-Seine à
droite ça continue à payer parce que
c'est un département de droite depuis
des décennies et que du coup les gens se
connaissent entre eux et que la liste
officielle ça marche mais la liste
dissidente ça marche aussi très bien en
revanche on voit bien que la gauche y
compris lorsqu'elle s'unit à beaucoup de
mal à progresser parce que il y a un
terreau une sociologie de droite qui
existe chez les chez les élus donc la
question de lauracinement la question
des
identités politiques territoriales elle
est aussi puissante et c'est au fond ça
que nous dit le fait Gérard Larcher qui
va être encore réélu c'est un
enracinement territorial profond et on
peut pas forcément aller contre ça et là
ce que vous disiez sur la gauche c'était
également pour les Hauts-de-Seine on est
bien d'accord c'était pas une question
il est clair que la gauche a très bien
performé ça a été rappelé si vous le
voulez qu'on parle du match dans le
match steward show au sein de cette
majorité présidentielle entre
Renaissance et horizon parce que même si
j'entends ce que nous dit François
Patriat Renaissance a plutôt perdu des
sénateurs le groupe horizon dirigé par
Claude malurey on a gagné il y a une
stratégie
d'ancrage local d'Edouard Philippe
derrière ça
je connais pas Édouard Philippe
personnellement donc je pourrai pas vous
répondre bah oui ou par non de manière
définitive mais je pense que oui en tout
cas il y a une ambition qui est portée
depuis quelques mois qui semble aussi
porter porter ses fruits et puis il y a
peut-être une logique de se distinction
assez nette avec le parti horizon qui
peut se réclamer d'un d'un ancrage et
d'une expérience des territoires qui
n'est pas forcément le cas pour le parti
de la majorité présidentielle et je
pense que c'est un facteur en tout cas
c'est un élément qui va falloir prendre
en compte et dans la majorité
présidentielle on en a conscience donc
cette force des territoires cette force
aussi voilà des électeurs sur le terrain
et des grands électeurs Philippe
réussiraient là où est Emmanuel Macron a
échoué d'une certaine façon une
expérience finalement du local et du
territoire et je pense que c'est aussi
ça qui fait la friction entre le parti
présidentiel et peut-être les ambitions
de l'ancien Premier ministre donc oui
c'est une une vraie clivage là
aujourd'hui d'expérience politique
d'histoire politique et peut-être même
de culture politique avoir s'il y a
voilà l'approche de 2027 ça ne peut pas
faire la différence
dans le sens de steward show Edouard
Philippe c'est un homme du Nouveau Monde
qui fait de la politique avec des
méthodes du jeu monde il s'est
parfaitement comment fonctionne un parti
il faut rappeler que c'était l'homme qui
avait créé l'UMP en son temps et lui et
persuadé que pour remporter l'élection
présidentielle il faut simplement
planter s'implanter localement et donc
aller essayer de convaincre les élus
locaux de se rallier à sa bannière ce
que n'a pas fait Renaissance on peut
entendre le communiquer avec des accents
triomphant de de François Patriat c'est
un naufrage c'est un naufrage pour ce
parti présidentiel qui est installé
depuis six ans au pouvoir on sait que
les municipales n'ont pas été bonnes ça
on le sait enfin il y a quand même
beaucoup de grands électeurs sans
étiquette est-ce que les gens de
Renaissance sont allés parler à à ces
grands électeurs est-ce qu'ils sont
allés convaincre ses mères c'est il y a
une cassure totale entre ce pouvoir et
ce parti présidentiel et les élus locaux
et là on en a vraiment un exemple absolu
et Edouard Philippe dans son coin depuis
Le Havre qui ratisse le terrain qui
décroche ici ou là des élus locaux
se constituer une force politique
sénatoriale au moins équivalente alors
une partez pas de rien Edouard Philippe
il était un ancien élu de LR mais on
voit bien que pour le coup il a réussi
en deux trois ans ce que Renaissance n'a
jamais réussi à faire Bruno cotes je
pense que ce point capital dans la
stratégie d'Édouard Philippe parce qu'au
fond montrer que lui il a du capital
politique dans les territoires qu'il a
des élus locaux qui sont avec lui ça lui
permet bien évidemment d'abord de se
différencier d'Emmanuel Macron en
entre les lignes ça renvoie le message
et bien que peut-être c'était ça aussi
qui était derrière le fait que Édouard
Philippe quitte ses responsabilité à
Matignon c'était pas seulement que le
président voulait changer le Premier
ministre mais peut-être aussi une
différenciation sur leur perception de
la société française et puis autre point
fondamental pour Édouard Philippe ça
peut lui permettre aussi et bien de se
situer et en plus en bonne position dans
la compétition interne au centre droit
vis-à-vis de la présidentielle parce que
s'il y a un terrain sur lequel le centre
droit est en train d'investir c'est la
question du local et on voit que
plusieurs des ténors du centre droit
dans le cas de l'élection présidentielle
veulent aller sur ce terrain leurvoquer
président de la Région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes Xavier Bertrand président
des Hauts de France David Lisnard depuis
Cannes donc on voit que sur la question
du local ils veulent sans doute embrayer
quelque chose qui est un projet
politique peut-être de redéfinir le
périmètre des relations entre État et
collectivités locales et donc Édouard
Philippe c'est très important qu'il soit
ancré territoriellement mais on va
essayer d'ailleurs c'est une question
qui va se poser dans les prochains jours
dans les prochaines semaines puisque
dans son discours sur la planification
écologique en cette fin d'après-midi
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé a confirmé
parce qu'il avait déjà évoqué la mise en
oeuvre de 13 RER métropolitains 700
millions d'euros abordés par l'État la
question c'est combien les collectivités
locales vont devoir mettre au pot aussi
pour que ces projets avancent je pense
que ça nous promet quelques débats
importants et peut-être le dans les
prochaines semaines allez on va
s'intéresser tout de suite au nouveau
venu dans ce
Sénat avec Quentin calmé dans un court
instant mais d'abord on écoute l'un
d'entre eux c'est Yann Brossat sénateur
nouveau sénateur communiste de Paris on
a plein de plein de choses à faire plein
de plein de formations
relatives au frais de mandat la gestion
des collaborateurs au régime de l'élu et
la protection sociale enfin on a
beaucoup de choses à
intégrer mais en tout cas ça se passe
bien et c'est une belle maison dans
laquelle on est on est bien accompagné
donc c'est sûr que ça ça aide les
prochaines journées sont bien remplies
mais j'ai quand même un peu hâte de
retourner sur le terrain notamment dans
mon arrondissement le 18e donc je vais
essayer dans la semaine de de garder
quelques créneaux pour pour voir des
gens dehors
allez comme promis on propose ce zoom
sur les personnalités qui ont marqué ce
scrutin sénatorial avec Quentin Calmet
bonsoir Quentin on commence à tous avec
le groupe écologiste on va commencer
effectivement avec par exemple la
réélection de Guillaume gontin qui est
le chef de fil des écologistes au Sénat
une réélection et également des nouveaux
arrivants pour ce groupe écologiste qui
passe de 12 à 16 sièges parmi ces
nouveaux entrants au Sénat et
écologistes il y a une figure connue du
grand public Yannick Jadot l'ancien
candidat à l'élection présidentielle en
2022 il est élu sur la liste du nom de
la Gauche à Paris et Nick Jadot passe
donc du Parlement européen à la chambre
haute du parlement français autre
personnalité élu sur cette liste du nom
de la Gauche à Paris et vous en parlez
il y a un instant c'est Yann Brossat il
est porte-parole du Parti communiste
français un proche de Fabien Roussel
alors d'autres personnalités importantes
ici au Sénat dont le siège était en jeu
hier soir par exemple le président du
Sénat à l'arraché qui effectivement est
élu pour la cinquième fois dans son
département des Yvelines prochaine étape
pour lui a priori l'élection à la
présidence du Sénat ça se joue le 2
octobre prochain on verra si dans les
prochains jours il est bien candidat à
sa succession et s'il est bien réélu le
2 octobre il est président de groupe du
Sénat oui à gauche le chef de fil des
socialistes Patrick caner et élu dans le
département du Nord son groupe le groupe
socialiste qui devrait afficher une
relative stabilité autour de 65 sièges
de sénateurs il s'agit du deuxième
groupe en importance ici à la Chambre
haute du parlement Patrick Kanner qui
pourrait faire avoir un face à lui un
concurrent au poste de président de
groupe socialiste puisque
Eric Kerrou chez lui dans les Landes
pourrait candidater pourrait
effectivement la présidence de groupe
troisième personnalité présidente de
groupe que je voulais évoquer Hervé
Marseille le chef de fil des centristes
du Sénat patron de l'UDI il est réélu
dans les Hauts-de-Seine les centristes
qui misaient sur de forts gains en
nombre de sièges notamment hier la
soirée électorale on verra si ça se
confirme ou si c'est pas plutôt et bien
une stabilité complète pour les centres
évidemment et on l'a évoqué dans notre
débat la majorité présidentielle qui
réalise quand même une mauvaise
performance une contreperformance on a
appris taux dans la journée d'hier
effectivement Sony caisse la secrétaire
d'État à la citoyenneté et qui est battu
en Nouvelle-Calédonie effectivement avec
le décalage horaire ça a été l'un des
premiers résultats de la journée
électorale et on a beaucoup parlé
effectivement oui oui ça a été même la
première information de ce scrutin sur
les sénatoriales hier effectivement en
plus dans le même temps un candidat
indépendantiste est élu dans cette
collectivité et d'outre-mer et ça c'est
une première pour la chambre haute du
parlement et on verra aussi Thomas
silaministre démissionne et applique une
jurisprudence encore vu l'année dernière
lors des élections législatives pour les
membres du gouvernement qui n'étaient
pas élus députés d'ailleurs une autre
ancienne ministre est battue lors de ces
sénatoriales Brigitte bourguignon
éphémère ministre de la Santé l'an
dernier elle avait échoué législative
avait dû quitter effectivement le
ministère de la Santé l'an dernier et
bien il échoue également au Sénat dans
le Pas-de-Calais et dans ce même
département le Pas-de-Calais c'est bien
sénateur RN et cellule s'appelle
Christopher Zurich c'est l'un des trois
sénateurs RN qui rentrent avec ce
renouvellement au snack fait son retour
le RNA au Sénat et effectivement le
retour cette formation politique c'est
l'une des informations majeures de la
journée d'hier merci beaucoup Quentin
pour pour toutes ces informations Lucile
Schmitt peut-être un mot de Sonia baquet
il y a pas de il y a pas de règle
institutionnel évidemment mais ce qui
peut rester au gouvernement après avoir
été battu même si vous nous l'avez dit
le contexte est particulier le contexte
est particulier et je ne sais pas je
sais pas ce qu'on va lui demander moi je
pense que il aurait peut-être mieux
partir et se concentrer sur la
Nouvelle-Calédonie au fond peut-être
qu'il y a quelque chose à faire si si on
veut défendre la position actuelle du
gouvernement qui est plutôt que la
Nouvelle-Calédonie reste française je
pense que ça a été dit c'est un
avertissement qu'un sénateur
indépendantiste entre au Sénat et que ça
veut dire qu'on peut pas courir
plusieurs lièvres à la fois c'est la
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est aux antipodes
la France il y a un grand décalage
horaire c'est l'hémisphère sud donc il
faut peut-être se concentrer là-dessus
en tout cas moi j'ai pas de leçon à
donner mais je pense que ça pourrait
être intéressant Bruno cotreesse
peut-être d'une manière générale est-ce
que il y a un rajeunissement une
féminisation même lente de du Sénat
après le scrutin d'hier est-ce que cette
tendance qui est pas une tendance rapide
mais qui est une tendance réelle
continue c'est sûr qu'il y a une
tendance au rajeunissement au Sénat
depuis ces dernières années qui sont la
mise en œuvre aussi des lois la parité
quand même qu'il y a deux articles la
Constitution qui disent que les la
République doit mettre en oeuvre le
principe de parité que les partis
politiques doivent éveiller donc c'est
aussi un effet de ces lois sur la sur la
parité appliquer également au corps des
grands électeurs très importants pour
l'élection du Sénat donc on voit
effectivement il y avait 36% de femmes
dans le Sénat sortant alors je n'ai pas
le détail des derniers chiffres mais
c'est vrai qu'on voit que ça progresse
progressivement il y a sans doute des
nouveaux visages un peu jeunes on a
repéré tout à l'heure
plusieurs nouveaux visages on en voit
que certains sont des cadres régénères
par exemple il y a aussi la nouvelle
benjamine nouvelle benjamine qui vient
du parti europécologie les Verts
Mathilde Olivier
au Sénat au Sénat au milieu de en
moyenne d'âge de 60 ans le Sénat les
député sécante neuf ans les sénateurs 60
donc c'est vrai mais c'est vrai que ça
progresse progressivement et on voit
dans différents postes de notre vie
publique cette féminisation et se
rajeunissement en même temps c'est bien
que le Sénat s'inscrive dans cette
tendance et puis surtout c'est bien que
les élections sénatoriales permettent de
nouveaux visages et avoir une nouvelle
forme d'incarnation c'est avec la
politique c'est beaucoup de
l'Incarnation pour porter des idées
aussi ça vous pour Yannick Jadot qui va
bien bien évidemment devenir sans doute
une des voix forte de cette nouvelle
Assemblée stewardshow justement
concernant Yannick Jadot Grand Brûlé de
la de l'élection présidentielle il peut
se refaire une santé au Sénat
que c'est un sacré Paris puisque après
15 ans je crois passer au Parlement
européen il revient dans l'arène
politique nationale alors oui c'est je
pense que c'est une manière aussi de de
réinvestir le débat public le débat
national on a quand même très peu
entendu depuis sa défaite en 2022 on
voit aussi que à gauche et politique
c'est quand même très tendu on ne sait
pas ce que va devenir cette alliance
conjoncturelle et de la nupaisse donc
qu'est-ce que ça va être finalement
Europe Écologie Les Verts avec Yannick
Jason entre guillemets de retour dans le
débat public national ça on le on le
verra il faut aussi quand même rappeler
que eny Jadot ne fait pas totalement
l'unanimité non plus Europe Écologie Les
Verts on le voit sur les questions
économiques on le voit aussi sur des
questions parfois de société on l'a vu
par exemple refuser de marcher contre
les violences policières avec tous les
débats qu'il y a eu caille autour donc
c'est un retour à voir s'il est gagnant
ou perdant on le verra dans les dans les
mois qui viennent juste peut-être un
chiffre d'opinion il est quand même à
17% de cotes de confiance d'avenir
Fabien Roussel est à 23% donc ça joue
dans un de poche mais tout ça pour dire
aussi qu'il n'y a pas une attente
extrêmement importante de la part
aujourd'hui de plus en public vis-à-vis
de Yannick Jadot et puis Mathieu à peine
élu au Sénat on le soupçonne de lorgner
sur la mairie de Paris donc il va devoir
prouver que ce n'est pas peut être un
tremplin ça peut être aussi un chose
trappe faut le savoir mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a Nick Jadot revient en France
et ils étaient ils avaient pas quitté la
France
européen et c'est vrai qu'il y a des
visées écologistes sur la mairie de
Paris parce que les écolos se disent
c'est peut-être notre tour maintenant
ils sont persuadés que la sociologie
électorale de Paris leur est
particulièrement favorable ça a été le
cas dans d'autres grands centres urbains
on le sait à Lyon à Strasbourg à Rennes
à Bordeaux on l'a vu et donc
ils ont jeté leur dévolu sur Paris après
ce qui est complexe et ça a été très
bien dit pas c'est que Yannick Jadot
n'est pas forcément majoritaire dans son
propre parti on se souvient qu'il avait
été désigné à la suite d'une primaire
qu'il avait vu vraiment au coude à coup
avec sa concurrente Sandrine rousse la
campagne présidentielle c'est très mal
par le passé le parti écologiste
rassemble plusieurs familles de pensées
rassemblent plusieurs individus et a du
mal à marcher du même pas et donc voilà
le Sénat et en tout cas un bon tremplin
pour revenir sur la scène politique
nationale est-ce que c'est un bon
tremplin pour Paris l'avenir de dire on
verra bien la chemise parce que ça on
l'a dit souvent ici le Sénat c'est une
assemblée où on travaille beaucoup sur
les textes sur les missions
d'information sur les commissions
d'enquête il va devoir faire ses preuves
tout avec malgré son expérience
politique je pense que le Parlement
européen est un endroit où on travaille
beaucoup aussi et que Yannick Jadot
avait convaincu sur la que sa capacité
de technicité en revanche j'entendais là
que il disait qu'il allait mouiller sa
chemise sur l'immigration je crains
qu'il soit assez minoritaire sur ses
positions au Sénat et sur ces questions
là le sujet c'est au fond quand on parle
d'être sénateur moi je me faisais la
réflexion qu'on est un peu au milieu du
guide c'est à dire qu'on voit bien que
il était assuré d'être élu c'était
franchement pas une élection très
risquée pour lui de devenir sénateur et
donc d'une certaine manière il y a
presque le sentiment profit d'une rente
de situation et donc pour revenir il
faut sortir de l'idée de la rente de
situation au fond on est désigné grâce à
un appareil pour aller se projeter
prendre une place dans la société
française sachant qu'il Yannick Jadot a
fait toutes ses preuves à l'échelle
européenne et non pas à l'échelle
nationale il a jamais été élu à
l'échelle nationale et on sait très bien
moi je trouve que par exemple Emmanuel
Macron est souvent en très bon sur les
questions européennes et à l'échelle
c'est un peu plus compliqué ça c'est mon
point de vue pour Yannick Jadot il est
il a été très bon je trouve à l'échelle
européenne par exemple sur les accords
commerciaux etc est-ce qu'il peut être
bon à l'échelle nationale c'est pas
forcément un automatisme et puis alors
il y a la question de Paris qui est
encore autre chose mais prendre pied en
France quand on a porté des textes
européens c'est pas si simple on va
évidemment consacrer notre dernier
chapitre à l'entrée de trois sénateurs
du rassemblement national ici à la Haute
Assemblée mais puisqu'on parle de
Yannick Jadot quand même le la question
de la nups de l'avenir de la nups Bruno
cotress parce que il y a eu un choix
stratégique de la gauche sénatoriale de
faire une alliance disait dans mes
titres l'union fait la force sans la
France insoumise est-ce que c'est l'une
des leçons de ce scrutin oui c'est une
des leçons importantes de ce scrutin qui
va rajouter une couche de complexité
dans une situation déjà assez complexe à
gauche on sait que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
dans les starting blocks pour en
découdre sur au fond est-ce que c'est
partenaires sont véritablement engagés
dans le même projet que lui on commence
à avoir des éléments importants de
différenciation sur la conception du
projet d'ensemble ce projet est parti au
fond des élections législatives et avant
du désastre des candidatures Hidalgo et
Jadot à l'élection présidentielle et du
sentiment de leurs appareils politiques
il fallait tourner une page et qu'il
fallait maintenant se lancer dans une
nouvelle construction pour réunifier la
gauche différemment donc on voit que il
y a maintenant un véritable on va dire
malentendu sur cette construction
politique
Jean-Luc Mélenchon veut l'ancrer dans sa
conception de l'Union Populaire qui vise
à dépasser les appareils politiques en
parler directement aux profondeur de la
de la société il n'a pas de mots assez
dur pour parler des vieux parti de la
gauche qui ont échoué et puis ben du
côté de ces vieux parties ils ont une
capacité de résidence très importante au
niveau local donc on voit cette
comptabilité très importante est-ce que
ces élections sénatoriales permettent de
tirer une conclusion plus générale sur
la nups beaucoup trop tôt c'est une
scrutin bien particulière c'est plutôt
au moment des élections européennes que
ça va se jouer admettons que des listes
séparés se présentent aux européennes
imaginons un scénario la France
insoumise serait par exemple devant les
écologistes alors là ça va rebatter 4 ça
va en remettre une couche de complexité
donc qui sera le premier entre en
particulier les écologistes les insoumis
va être une dimension fondamentale
steward show comment l'opinion parce que
on rappelle que si Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est arrivé troisième à la dernière
élection présidentielle c'est parce
qu'il y a une demande d'union de la part
d'électeur de gauche qui était pas
forcément
pas forcément envie depuis des mois et
des mois de voter la France insoumise
mais qui se sont dit ok c'est le vote
efficace bon ça on l'a déjà analysé
plusieurs fois ici le spectacle de la
nupes depuis alors peut-être médiatique
mais le spectacle de la dupez depuis des
semaines voire des mois c'est quand même
le spectacle de la désunions c'est ce
qui ressort et donc comment c'est perçu
par les les électeurs de de cette
famille politique comme vous l'écrivez
très bien c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a un
brouillage aujourd'hui à gauche du
message qui est absolument
comment dire consternant pour les
électeurs de gauche d'ailleurs mes
confrères avaient fait un portrait
comparé entre LFI le rassemble nationale
et on voyait bien que son un certain
nombre de de d'indicateurs à la fois sur
le danger pour la démocratie sur la
dimension de respectabilité le ratio
national faisait beaucoup mieux
aujourd'hui que LFI donc elle affiche
par le RFI parce que sur la news
effectivement il y a une forme
d'hégémonie un peu de la France
insoumise qui dérange une certaine
nombre de de personnalités politiques on
parlait de Yannick Jadot c'est pas non
plus le plus grand avant et partenaires
de la nupesse Yann brossa non plus il a
déjà déclaré que voilà il pourrait aussi
y avoir une vie après laupes donc il y a
effectivement une forme de déception de
désillusion donc l'Union les électeurs
de gauche ils sont attachés mais l'union
avec qui et c'est aussi ça qu'il faut
qu'il faut essayer de comprendre et
d'analyser aujourd'hui ce qui est
absolument certain c'est qu'il y a pas
d'alternative pour l'instant assez
crédible pour les électeurs de gauche
au-delà de cette de cette nupes là les
élections européennes vont être un
indicateur assez intéressant ok merci
beaucoup Stewart d'ailleurs ça va se
jouer aussi au Sénat pour la la
présidente du groupe socialiste puisque
face à Patrick kaner qui est pas grand
fan de la nupesse on va dire ça comme ça
il y a Eric et rouge qui est proche
d'Olivier fort donc ça va aussi être un
élément intéressant des prochains jours
comme promis on termine avec la question
du rassemblement national avant de vous
donner la parole Mathieu votre analyse
sur l'entrée de 3 sénateurs RN on écoute
l'un d'entre eux Christopher Zurich dans
le Pas-de-Calais
je suis évidemment heureux je fais
extrêmement fier je suis très satisfait
aussi j'en parle vraiment des résultats
en eux-mêmes parce que finalement je
double mon résultat par rapport à 2017
j'arrive en troisième position ce qui
était pas forcément attendu ni par moi
ni par les autres ce qui veut dire aussi
que j'ai réussi à rassembler que le
rassemblement national a réussi à
rassembler largement au-delà de ces
seuls grands électeurs il y a forcément
je pense et je l'avais bien senti
pendant la campagne des électeurs issus
de toutes les formations politiques des
élus non étiquetés qui nous ont accordé
leur confiance et ça c'est sans doute
aussi une grande victoire aujourd'hui
Mathieu peut-on parler d'un succès pour
le parti de Marine Le Pen ah bah c'est
en tout cas ce que le rassemblement
national clairon depuis hier soir
l'anomalie démocratique que constituait
l'absence du RN au Sénat est réparée
disait parti dans un communiqué assurant
que le rassemblement national progresse
fortement et poursuit ça marche vers le
pouvoir alors bon trois sièges c'est
évidemment mieux que rien nous de rien
c'est d'où partait le rassemblement
national et en ce sens c'est une forme
de Persée le rassemblement national a
déjà compté deux en 2014 on se souvient
David Racheline avait fini lui par
préférer sa mairie de Fréjus au Palais
du Luxembourg et puis Stéphane Ravier le
Marseillais lui il était passé avec arms
zebagage pendant la dernière campagne
présidentielle vous en souvenez dans le
camp d'Éric Zemmour du coup le RN
n'avait plus rien au Palais du
Luxembourg mais ce que c'est un triomphe
non plus parce que pour un parti ou
certains rêvaient secrètement de
décrocher jusqu'à 6 sièges ils ne font
que trois sièges et puis il y a des
départements la Moselle par exemple ou
les Pyrénées-Orientales ou le
rassemblement national comptait
enregistrer en tout cas de bien meilleur
score avec quand même un mode de scrutin
de ces élections sénatoriales qui est
pas forcément favorable au rassemblement
de la faiblesse de son implantation
locale et du coup du nombre réduit de
ces grands électeurs puis en 2020 le
rassemblement national c'était quand
même banané aux municipales il faut le
dire ils avaient perdu un grand nombre
de conseillers municipaux la bonne
surprise en fait pour ces trois élus
c'est quand même et c'est ce qu'on vient
d'entendre dans la bouche du nouveau
sénateur du Nord
donc c'est c'est d'avoir réussi à
rallier de nombreux suffrages chez des
grands électeurs non encartés et pour le
coup le RN progresse dans de nombreux
départements en particulier dans ce ou
Marine Le Pen était arrivé en tête au
premier tour ça c'est le cas du Nord ou
dans ce où elle est arrivée en tête au
premier tour et au second tour à la
présidentielle comme dans le
Pas-de-Calais alors on a entendu l'un
d'entre eux quelques informations qui
sont ces nouveaux élus aux trois hommes
moins de 40 ans et qui sont pas des
inconnus au RN c'est pas forcément des
figures historiques du parti qu'on
militait dans dans les mouvements de
jeunesse de l'extrême droite mais ils
sont bien connus au RN de Christopher
Zurich dans le Pas-de-Calais donc lui
petit fils de 2000 heures polonais fils
d'ouvriers en quarté à la CGT c'est un
proche de Steve Briois Steve Briois
c'est le maire d'énim-beaumont un des
premières Edils des premiers édit d'îles
pardon du rassemblement national très
proche de Marine Le Pen un peu en odeur
de moins en odeur de santé avec
l'appareil frontiste mais en tout cas
c'est vraiment une figure qui qui l'a
paterné il essaie sur son premier
adjoint à Ste ensuite on a Joshua
Hauchard lui c'est un conseiller
municipal d'opposition à Denain donc
pour le coup dans le Nord et lui c'est
un très proche de Sébastien Chenu
vice-président du groupe RN à
l'Assemblée La Voix du Nord disait que
voilà il quitte l'ombre de Sébastien
Chenu pour vivre sa propre histoire et
puis on a
probablement la vraie surprise de ces
trois-là c'est Emery Emeric pardon Durox
en Seine-et-Marne donc Aymeric du rock
en Seine-et-Marne lui c'est un
professeur d'histoire-géographie qui a
commencé ses classes politiques dans le
mouvement chevènementiste il est
conseillé régional en Île-de-France il
s'est présenté plusieurs fois au
législative elle était battue et c'est
une figure maintenant du rassemblement
national sur place mais pour la
Seine-et-Marne où on sait qu'il y a
quand même un vote Le Pen on se pensait
pas forcément que ça c'est un vote
favori où est-ce qu'ils vont siéger
c'est pas un groupe 1 3 sénateurs
du diagramme qu'on a montré au début de
l'émission aux côtés de leur ancien
camarade Stéphane Ravier et faute de
groupe au Palais du Luxembourg ils vont
bénéficier de l'appui et du soutien bien
en tout cas de l'expertise de leur
collègue députés qui eux sont très
nombreux on le rappelle puisqu'ils ont
fait rentrer en force au Palais Bourbon
en juin dernier hallucine est-ce que
c'était effectivement une anomalie le
fait qu'il y a pas de sénateur du
rassemblement national écoutez c'était
une anomalie heureuse pour moi donc
voilà après ce que je me disais surtout
par rapport à tout ce qui a été rappelé
par Mathieu sur l'historique c'est que
avant il venait du Sud maintenant c'est
le Nord le Pas-de-Calais et la
Seine-et-Marne je me rappelais aussi en
vous écoutant que la Seine-et-Marne
c'est un des départements dans lequel le
mouvement des gilets jaunes a commencé
et d'une certaine manière je pense que
ça signifie des conseillers municipaux
des grands électeurs aujourd'hui
considèrent comme justement une anomalie
alors qu'ils sont pas au RN que le RN ne
soit pas représenté donc pour moi c'est
une anomalie heureuse mais quand on est
grand électeur et qu'on est non inscrit
on peut au fond se dire mais il faut
réparer une anomalie ne serait-ce que
parce que moi peut-être je fais le paru
où je pense que le RN va continuer à
progresser dans les échanges à venir
donc c'est aussi quelque chose qui se
révèle un état d'esprit me semble-t-il
chez certains de nos élus sur l'idée
qu'au fond il y a quelque chose
d'irrépressible qui est en train de se
passer et moi je trouve que c'est
évidemment pour nous une alerte c'est
pas parce qu'on a trois que c'est pas
une grosse salaire parce que ça signifie
que et d'ailleurs ils sont tardes des
gens qui ne sont pas ORL on voté pour
eux dans le secret de l'urne et au fond
que sur le RN les calculs les calculs
d'apothicaire
ne servait à rien que un certain nombre
de personnes ont déjà un peu basculé et
du coup la question de la loi migration
immigration me semble être un point
important il y aura peut-être Yannick
Jadot d'un côté de l'autre côté les
sénateurs RN et on peut déjà assister
peut-être à quelque chose qui se jouera
aussi à l'échelle européenne l'année
prochaine et ça fera partie évidemment
des thèmes dont on va débattre avec mes
invités politiques dans dans quelques
minutes Bruno cotress ils ne sont que
trois on peut dire ces symbolique ils
vont pas peser par leur vote sur sur
tous les débats mais ce
processus de normalisation finalement
dans une institution aussi ancrée que le
Sénat c'est pas neutre quoi d'avoir
trois sénateurs c'est pas c'est pas
neutre et c'est à la fois c'est la vie
démocratique c'est le rôle des
institutions de faire rentrer dans
l'assemblée les différents courants de
pensée de la société c'est le rôle des
institutions canalisées les passions
humaines les passions politiques faire
en sorte que tout le monde se sente ce
centre présenté et de ce point de vue là
c'est vrai que le sujet des anomalies ou
des disproportionnalités ça c'est un mot
savant pour parler du contraste entre la
répartition des sièges et la répartition
des tempéraments politiques dans la
société c'est un grand sujet de
réflexion politique qui se pose dans
toutes les dans toutes les assemblées
sans doute qu'un jour des réflexions
reviendront sur les différentes
modalités de scrutin des différentes des
différentes assemblées donc voilà ça
c'est un thème permanent de débat en
démocratie et c'est bien que les
institutions jouent le rôle d'absorber
de rendre compte de ce qui se passe dans
société parce que sinon si les
institutions ne font pas ça et ben les
gens vont s'exprimer en dehors et on
sait que dans la société française le
niveau de conflictualité en dehors des
assemblées voire parfois l'intérêt des
assemblées est très élevé déjà si voir
son parler de la difficulté de l'ancrage
local notamment pour Emmanuel Macron et
ses amis est-ce que on assiste même s'il
y a eu effectivement des élections
municipales qui étaient des autres pour
le rassemblement national en 2020 est-ce
qu'on assiste quand même notamment dans
les régions de Montpellier un vrai
ancrage local aujourd'hui ce qui est
vrai je rejoindrai ce qui vient d'être
dit c'est qu'il y a une
une conquête aujourd'hui de rationnaire
auprès de grands électeurs qui
apprivoisent aujourd'hui le vote un vote
rassemblement national aujourd'hui alors
on a parlé de respectabilité normalité
maintenant c'est voilà un parti qui est
aujourd'hui légitime légitime et
monocotresse dirait le disait très
justement il dit à sier dans nos
institutions qui sont là pour
institutionnaliser le conflit aussi
politique et donc représenter les forces
politiques de la nation mais c'est
peut-être aussi un indice qui montre que
le sujet du territoire le sujet du rural
le sujet de ces de ces zones dont on
parle peut-être un peu plus ces
dernières années est en train de devenir
un des termes du conflit politique en
tout cas des mois et des années qui
viennent donc ce n'est pas non plus
inintéressant Mathieu tout dernier mot
rapide dernier mot même ceux qui ont
raté les candidats qui ont raté à ce
moment national ont raté avec plus de
voix que par le passé merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat lucid schmitch je vais rappeler le
titre de votre livre Emmanuel Macron à
contretemps qui est publié aux éditions
Bayard à très bientôt sur sur Public
Sénat merci encore de d'avoir participé
à cette émission Monsieur Merci vous
avez laissé la place à notre débat 100%
politique on se retrouve évidemment
mercredi